Speaker 1: There may be, however, one way that
it could be worth it. And that is if Joe Manchin
agrees to kill the filibuster so that Democrats
can pass the John Lewis Voting Rights Act.
And the reason that piece of
legislation is so dang important
is because of the new report we got this week,
according to a new report from CNN. You have
multiple Republican controlled states out
there, including some who have already passed
restrictive voting measures this year that already
have a full slate of legislation, with even more
restrictions heading our way in 2022. Let me read
this. Lawmakers in four states already have pre
filed at least 13 bills for the 2022 legislative
sessions. That would make it harder to cast a
ballot. That is, of course, according to the
Brennan Center for Justice. In five states, six
pre filed bills would allow audits or reviews of
election results as former President Donald Trump
and his allies continue to baselessly attribute
his 2020 loss to election fraud. In addition,
some 88 restrictive bills that were introduced
but failed to become law in nine states this year
are expected to carry over into legislative
session set to begin early next year. And
let's not forget that so far in 2021, 19
states passed 34 restrictive voting bills.
Because this is what they do. Because this is the
only way that Republicans can win. They can't win
on the issues. They can't win on economics. They
can't win on policy. They can't win on populism.
I know Trump did in 2016, but technically he
lost the popular vote. So what do they do?
They do two things they resort to culture war
issues, which they've been fairly successful with
this year. And, of course, voter suppression
keep just enough people out of the way.
And we might be able to have a victory. Drum
up even more support from our crazed base
with these culture war issues by talking about
critical race theory and transgender athletes.
And we might be able to eke out a victory. And
of course, they're helped along the way with
gerrymandering, which is going to play a huge role
in the 2022 elections. The only X factor out there
right now is how many people died from
COVID that would vote for Republicans,
according to the numbers we're seeing right now. A
lot. So they're going to have to contend with that
continuing to push anti-mask and anti-vax
viewpoints isn't going to work out so well for
them electorally. So of course, they have to push
these restrictive voting bills. And as I said,
one of the worst parts of this is some of
these are in states that have already passed
restrictive voting measures this year. Florida and
Georgia are the top two. Georgia is still trying
to go even further, according to this new report,
by further limiting drop boxes, further limiting.
Collection of ballots. And, of course,
cutting down on the number of polling places
in a given county. Florida, again, I
mentioned this earlier this week. They
want to create a new $5 million office whose
job it is to go around and find voter fraud,
which I mean does exist to a small degree,
certainly not in in enough numbers to sway
an election. And of course, most of the cases
we're finding here in Florida are Republicans,
so that's probably not going to work out very
well for them. But that's what they're doing
and they're doing it because they can't win on the
issues. They can't when talking to normal people.
So they shut them out. They get them out of
the system, get them off the voting rolls by
any means necessary because that is their
only path to victory. They've been hugely
successful with it in the past and most of these
places where these bills are being proposed.
There's not enough opposition to prevent them
from becoming law before the 2022 election.